sure go ahead do what comes naturally
there's a beast lurking inside all of us
but the creature sheriff Big B harbors
is difficult to keep silence in the wolf
among us episode to smoke and mirrors
you can determine just how sharp Big B's
claws can dig whether you're dealing
with a mouthy murder suspect a cowering
child or a jealous husband who sniffs
wrongdoing in the smoky air in Fabletown
Big B's former identity as the big bad
wolf is an open secret but it's hardly
the only one the fables that live there
need to keep their identities a secret
from the masses in smoke and mirrors
however it becomes clear just how
intricate fable town's web of lies and
charades really is given the episodes
title it's no wonder you can't trust
even what your eyes can see if you play
it episode 1 you likely have a good idea
of who Big B is at least I know who my
Big B is an impatient bastard who shows
little restraint when cornered but is
fiercely protective of fable town's most
vulnerable residents as the episode
leads you through its story points you
can express both sympathy and savagery
admit I took some inner delight when
pummeling a sickening suspect until he
cried mercy but later when I got to my
knees to speak to a diminutive witness
my heart filled with compassion it was
when jealousy intruded on my
investigation that I realized how
attached to Big B I to come I was angry
at the assumptions my accuser was making
and so I let out my inner wolf damn did
it feel good
I'm gonna get a swig of that oh god I'm
cutting your throat next I'm sorry that
I can't be more specific explaining the
details would dull the story's bite
besides as you navigate your way through
smoke and mirrors multiple crime scenes
events may play out differently I
appreciated how the game acknowledged my
previous choices in its details however
a smashed wall and a missing limb were
sober visual reminders of past misdeeds
that made me more mindful of the
Barbarian I could be the atmosphere
continues to be the series greatest
triumph the heaving soundtrack the spot
on voice acting and the violet skies
make it easy to take potty-mouth toads
and snarling trolls absolutely seriously
nonetheless smoke and mirrors
occasionally feels like it's spinning
its wheels there are a few of the
QuickTime button events that give the
first episode such tension and their
narrative stakes aren't as high as a
result the game simmers but never quite
boils over dealing with smoke and
mirrors relatively harmless lowlifes
doesn't have the same appeal as bashing
in the woodsman's head even when they
deserve a smack in the mouth now and
again much of the time you're left
investigating crime scenes and
interrogating fables which can lead to
some minor but noticeable idiosyncrasies
Big B's tone of voice might change from
one line to the next as branches
separate and then converge and at one
point a character dropped a plot point
out of the blue that made me think the
line wasn't intended for my particular
branch of questioning ultimately smoke
and mirrors feels like a necessary
bridge spanning the wolf among us is
impactful first episode and the events
portrayed in the episode 3 preview that
concludes this one it smolders more than
it burns though in some sense that's an
appropriate trajectory for Big D's
ongoing investigation there's a moment
where Big B lights a cigar and
contemplates his next step that's
exactly where the wolf among us stands
now percolating and pondering before the
next punch to the guts the Seas mind
pointing me